I cannot believe that it's only 4 weeks until the local
and European elections.
This is a particularly exciting election for the Social Democrats
because the first time ever
that everyone in the country can vote Social Democrats.
So exciting seeing all the posters going up around the country.
And it has me reflecting on when I went for the local elections.
My first ever election
actually lost by a single vote and called a recount.
And after several greeting recounts,
I won by a single vote. I just like during the recount,
was thinking back to the things people did
in the lead up to that election.
I had a friend who made it her business to ask everybody she met
where they registered to vote
and then talking them through the process
if they weren't making sure they got registered.
There was a woman who got in touch in the final days
and asked for some leaflets to canvas her Parish.
And during the recount,
I remember seeing the box being recounted from that Parish
and realising how big an impact those seemingly small actions
at the time had on the overall results of that election.
And so I wanna ask you
if you wanna see your local Social Democrats candidates elected,
change starts in the community.
To please do everything you can between now and June 7th
to get those candidates elected.
Drop a leaflet, knock on the door,
make a donation, put up a poster,
register someone,
To vote ask somebody to vote Social Democrats on June 7th.